e
good morning everybody and welcome to
yet another edition of the environment
committee I'd like to open this meeting
this morning with uh representative
Allegiance Al to flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
all thank
you so today we have um five of our
retained
bills uh that we are going to discuss uh
folks have had some amendments drawn up
for these bills
and we'll go over those amendments and
uh and have some
discussions
um before that I'm interested to know
um we have some subcommittees that have
been meeting is that
correct is correct H as anybody would
anybody like to give us a a brief uh
update as to how the subcommittees are
doing okay so put your yeah good morning
representative Bixby so we have a a
study committee on
um uh looking at RSA chapters 426 and
434 uh at our last meeting we worked our
way through uh 426 we found some things
that uh can be eliminated some things
that a couple of things that need a
little bit of adjustment some things
that are working just fine um and uh
next week uh not actually not next week
um this afternoon uh as as rep cron so
kindly reminded me U we have another
meeting and we're going to be at that
point we're going to be looking at 4:34
my guess is that 4:34 will'll probably
have even more things that can be
eliminated uh and uh some things that
can be retained and may need some
updating and then we will come up with a
report and some legislation and um
that's how that's progressing yes thank
you very much for that anyone else
representative
[Music]
kraton uh yes Madam chair we have a uh
subcommittee meeting next week on
monitoring the rules for the waste water
based on the the work that was done last
last time Dees is going to come and talk
to us about how that Ru Mak process is
going what rules they're coming up with
to improve groundwater security around
in and around waste water
plants or waste waste plant waste
facilities landfills thank
you anyone
else oh representative ger thank you
very much uh for the study committee on
the unlimited area uh permits out of
state trash that the the chair was uh
kind enough to come and talk to us about
last week we'll have our final meeting
next week to pull together a report uh
one of the things we found in terms of
dealing with out estate trash is is to
try to limit it there kind of three
options one is uh you set stricter rules
for everybody which would be in state
and out of state another would be there
are various possibilities where you
could challenge uh the interstate
commerce clause and then take your
chances in court uh or there's the
possibility that future landfills are
owned uh publicly either by the state or
a political subdivision and then you
could restrict out of state trash
without worrying about the interstate
commerce clause so we're going to meet
next week we're going to draft up our
report and make some recommendations
thank you for
that uh anyone else representative Bixby
so uh I'm also on the study committee
for um finding more Slaughter facilities
for amendable and non-amendable animals
and um this is uh continues to be a
complicated issue uh one it looks like
one thing that will help is if we um
change in the definition of livestock in
statute so that uh non-amendable and
amendable are treated separately and
that will allow the uh the slaughter of
non-edible species in the uh state to
not track directly with USDA because the
USDA doesn't for some reason care about
non amendable species at least not to
the point of wanting to ma manage the
slaughter um and and uh in terms of
coming up with more solutions for um for
amenable animals it remains challenging
and uh that's we're going to be getting
some input unfortunately not in person
from the USDA local um food and F fsis
person um to uh find out more about how
the slaughter regulations work so we're
basically going to be submitting
questions to him he's going to give us
written replies um unfortunately he
wasn't able to come up so um which would
have been much easier because a back and
forth is better okay thank you very much
for that anyone else representative
Davis you're on the epr study committee
are you not good morning thank you madam
chair I think our study's done the test
testimony was very one-sided and I I
would have liked to have seen some more
testimony from the other side but I I I
believe we're going to be split U two
two for it two I don't know if it
opposed to it but but my opinion I
believe that
uh that they're not taking the right
approach to it I I don't I I think that
it's not probably uh something that I
would I think the free market should
determine what
uh you know what how we go forward with
this
um yeah we we're pretty much split
okay all right anyone else for any of
the other study committees or
subcommittees that have been going on no
I want to thank you all uh who are
serving on these study committees and
subcommittees for your work uh it's very
important and U I'm I'm happy to hear
that that there's some progress being
made on
these with that being said um let's uh
start off with um discussion about HB 37
establishing a committee to study best
practices for companion animal groomers
and as we left this last time um we had
said that
um instead of going along and uh um
putting together a a committee to study
best practices for companion animal
groomers that we would put together a
Consumer's Guide to choosing an animal
groomer and have that posted up on a um
State website probably through the
Department of
Agriculture um I came up with a a draft
and distributed to
distributed it to our members and I'm
looking for uh your feedback back and uh
if there's any editss or changes or
whatever let's discuss
it representative
Katon uh thank you ma'am the uh I read
through your draft and to me that makes
a lot more sense than uh than having a
committee and as wide as we can publish
that and get that out there it gets the
information into the hands of the
consumer so that they can make an
informed decision so I I think you've
hit the me on head and uh I like what
you've done thank you I uh I had input
from the um American Kennel Club the
dogs uh group um and also um there's a a
a cat groomer who uh who also gave me
some uh resources and also provided some
inputs uh some edits to the first draft
so I have I I distributed out to
everybody uh a first draft and then also
sent out the edited version um and I
know representative kto you had some
comments I did thank you I'm bring that
up real quick sure thank you madam chair
um it's not so much I like the idea of
having this out there um but on number
one
um it's kind of a misleading thing
because if you ask an establishment how
long they've been in business business
it could be that they've been in
business for 50 years but a new owner
just took over ah and so they've only
been in business for a day okay um and
the other thing is is um and maybe
there's someone that worked for another
business and then branched out on their
own and if they've only been in business
for a week uh people may not you know I
think start by asking friends families
and neighbors is more
important and I understand maybe asking
how long the establishment has been in
business but that can actually be kind
of controversial based on how it's
brought about and you could you know
someone could say well this has been in
business for 50 years and you have a bad
owner that just started and you could
bring your vet pet there or you could
have someone that's only been in
business for a week and they've been
doing it for 20 years um and that was my
only comment all right um well any kind
of uh change to the language that you
have for that section I'd be happy to
incorporate into the into this guide
representative Bixby I think that um one
of the things I like about this is it
doesn't provide just one Avenue for
figuring out what uh what the what your
best option is it provides a whole lot
of different approaches and uh and
implied in that is or might actually be
be stated explicitly I can't remember
but uh but that indicates that you don't
just ask for you know recommendation you
do a a number of different steps to
cross reference so that uh you know if
you you know if you ask how long they've
been in business and you you know it's
been the business has been around for um
50 years but you ask uh neighbors or you
know you ask other for other information
and you say yeah well we like the old
guy but this new guy is terrible then
then you're that's going to give you the
cross referencing information you need
so I I think that um having the the
multiple resources and indicating that
you that people should pursue more than
one of the these Avenues as a way of
getting their their information is
probably sufficient and U my more
General comment is that I think you did
a really great job on this and I I think
this is thank you and and I also have a
question which is have you talked with
the Department about what it would take
to get this put
up thank first of all thank you for uh
uh your comments and uh yes I have had
uh some conversation with commissioner
Jasper on this he was um very tentative
as to whether or not this is something
that belongs on their website he was
saying that he thought perhaps maybe
this should go on the state
veterinarians website or some uh you
know where where they do um Licensing in
the state um we were going to have some
further conversation about um where it
should go so um I'll have to have
further conversation with the
commissioner on that representative ktoa
thank you madam chair um one site that
maybe uh where it really would work well
is uh and you could talk with them is
the uh governance Council on the Humane
treatment of animals website ah okay um
because that really does talk to the
effect of humanely treating animals and
obviously we want to make sure that our
pet groomers are doing that exactly that
and it Encompass would Encompass that so
just a thought okay U and it could be
put on multiple
websites yeah I I I agree with that I
think probably you know wherever we can
put it up on the state websites that
would make it um accessible to the
consumers and that the general public
would be helpful
when um and I did
get hang on one second I did get uh
feedback
from uh the prime
sponsor uh Jim maiori representative
miori
and
um he his his comments to me was um your
guide should he wished he could have
attended the work session today um and
he said the guide should provide
consumers and groomers alike with a
solid framework from which to understand
the importance of what is necessary to
provide proper grooming services for our
pets based on the tragedy that motivated
the bill and similar conversations with
res residents whose pets were also
mistreated my only thought on your
excellent
guide is flipping number two research
and check credentials and number one
recommendations and how long the
establishment has been in business so
just to flip those two
I'm that's his his comment for an edit
um thank you and all the members of the
committee again for your work on this
bill so he's he's real happy with this
um I think he did a great job okay great
go ahead thank you madam chair um I'm
sorry representative Murray no that's
okay um one of the so that was one of
the other things I was thinking about
was obviously we know that this is a
guide that could be in part geared
towards the consumer but also then for
the groomers uh where would there be you
know I understand we're saying the the
governor's Council for Humane treatment
of animals could it also potentially go
somewhere else that um is accessible
then for those um groomers themselves so
that they have it and they're aware that
these are questions that their customers
and consumers may ask yeah well I think
they can access the state websites as
well but I also know that any of the
organizations the animal organizations
that they may belong to have their own
um guidelines on groomers and grooming
and some of them even have um mechanisms
to do credentialing for them so I
believe they uh they already probably
are well aware of um resources for best
practices for their for their
craft representative
Howard good morning good morning Madam
chair um given that we are sort of
taking this alternative route to avoid
legisl legislating regulations I think
that um the we don't need to fret too
much about number one I mean there's a
whole list of things to consider and and
and I agree with um all here that this
is beautifully put together and
sufficient so um I think that we don't
need to worry about uh about uh whether
somebody you know assumes a business and
can assume that those number of years
even though they they're they've only
been in it for one
year okay thank you anyone
else oh representative Penza good
morning morning so there's just a couple
additions that I would love
um they're already kind of in yours and
they would be added so one is like um
you know in regards with the pet that is
nervous and stuff about may I stay and
watch while you grew my dog like a
question to be asked so um another one
is specifically experience with um a
dog's breed which can go in another
paragraph in here and then the other one
is specifically about these are just
like questions to ask um what kind of
training do they have so um you know
because of course some groomers I have a
very good friend she completely learned
on the job you know through an
apprenticeship and that can be just as
good as you know getting of course the
safe training and all those other types
of things so um I have like three
sentences and if you want I'll grab
paragraphs and send them to you a little
later today it sounds wonderful send me
whatever um addition you'd like to have
included and I'll do that I'll come up
with a final draft and then um send it
out along to all of you and then get in
touch with I will get in touch with um
commissioner Jasper and we'll discuss uh
where to place this on state
websites okay any other represent
dsy uh yes thank you madam chair um I
was struck by the number of resources
that were listed and and I do think you
did an excellent job but my question
became is would there have been a
different avenue to take to get the same
result without it going through a
legislative committee um you know I mean
a lot of time has been allocated to this
I think we've come up with a great
solution but the fact of the matter is
if anybody would have done a Google
search they probably could have come up
you know with at least one of these
resources MH so so my question here is
there you know should we be educating
our representatives to or are there are
are there resources within you know the
state house that they could go to to
determine whether or not it should be a
bill or there should be some other
Avenue I think we need to explore that
okay thank
you
Ma all right
any other comments questions concerns
then we can move on to HB 122 which is
relative to microenterprise home kitchen
operations and I will um turn this over
to representative ktoa who has presented
us with an
amendment thank you madam chair um so
what I've done is we've adding a new
section called homemade
food um and there's some definitions in
there uh it's on your desk if you give
everyone a chance to take a look at it
and we're talking
about uh someone making homemade food
and then transferring it or selling it
to an informed end consumer and just to
let you know an informed and consumer
means a person who is the last person to
purchase a product
does not resell the product and has been
informed that the product is not
licensed permitted certified packaged
labeled or inspected per any official
regulations and right now we have people
with bake sales we have people with
community events and there really is no
true legal Avenue for them to be doing
selling you know having that food there
because they can't technically I mean
it's kind of like the lemonade stand
right you're making your lemonade and
technically legally you can't sell it to
the ined end consumer who's going by to
purchase that cup of
lemonade so um it's pretty specific it
excludes retail
establishments it excludes wholesale
food manufacturing
establishments a dairy or manufactured
um so uh you know it
excludes certain things but it includes
your traditional Community social events
and there is a list of those on on that
is on page
two um I think this accomplishes what we
were trying to accomplish especially
with the EP thing the episode that
happened up in Meredith where the person
was uh donating food from her kitchen to
people that couldn't afford it she
wasn't even selling it um but she was
donating it and I think that the
consumer at some point has to take
responsibility and as long as they're
informed of what's in the product they
understand that it's not licensed or
permitted um why can't you buy from your
representative
Katon uh thank you m'am uh
representative kto I think you you uh
you hit what I wanted to see in the bill
which is a couple of things um one uh
consumer awareness if the consumer is
aware of what they're buying then then
it should be allowed uh for for them to
do that uh the second thing is you took
out the controversial part about the
milk specifically so that's included in
other law that we don't have to include
in here and uh third it opens up um it
opens up the Avenues for private people
that want to do things on on their own I
think that's uh in the spirit of of what
you representative Murray good morning
thank you madam chair um and thank you
um so a couple of things first I and
not I want to be clear that I think what
we were talking a little bit about a
couple of different things one of which
was donations to nonprofit entities or
organizations which I do believe is
covered through the bill Emerson Good
Samaritan act so that's I think a
separate entity and conversation unto
itself when we're talking about this
issue I did want to ask
um what would be the me mechanism to
ensure that some somebody has been
informed is there a way to make sure is
that
a
um do could could there be any sort of
enti like situation where somebody says
oh well I didn't see that or I wasn't I
didn't know um and then are we getting
into a situation where there there's an
assumed liability there
because I guess that's the question okay
thank you I represent Mari so an
informed and consumer is someone who
speaks with the producer or their agent
about what the food is I mean the
questions now I'm going to speak from
personal experience and also in
general most
people that are doing any type of home
business or anything like that are not
looking to harm anybody and in a small
state like New Hampshire if if you do
one thing that's not so good everybody
in your community knows it and you're
done I mean it's really um it's kind of
you know word travels bad news travels
really fast um and I think that we have
to let people take responsibility at
some point we cannot
regulate every little thing in someone's
life and I think this is one of
them we're not saying that they're
selling these you know in retail stores
or anything
else
and and if you want to go and be able to
sell certain things then you can go
under the Homestead Act this is for very
small private businesses or people just
trying to make an End meat maybe there's
a mom that says you know what I need a
few extra dollars to buy my groceries
this week and if I can just make a
couple of meals for my neighbor and
maybe she can buy them I mean we as
people bring food to our neighbors
already and technically if you if you're
looking at the Spirit of the law you're
really not supposed to be doing
that because you're it's from a private
home and you're bringing it to an
informed end consumer and that's what
about representative Murray um follow up
if I may sure um and then uh just one
other quick question I had was just for
continuity sake I we there's I I think
we briefly touched on this there's one
mention of the word Cottage food
operation and the rest it it is
mentioned as Homestead food so I just
for clarity sake is that a different
thing or is that the same thing in
language so um I would I'm not sure why
that is but I will look into that uh
with OS thank you
um representative
ger thank you madam chair uh the the
question I have is a question I often
have is when we talk about local control
um in in the state and we generally say
that we prefer local control but I'm
often confused with legislation that not
only forbids a state agency from
acquiring things but also forbids
localities from being able to uh to do
some of these things as well so to say
that a political subdivision is barred
from uh having any requirements for
example uh pertaining to preparation of
food as an example um I wonder about so
my question is uh aside from forbidding
a state agency from doing it what is the
um the purpose of the the virtue of also
us saying that localities can't make
so thank you for the question
representative jamer and I understand
what you're saying however this goes
to this isn't for someone who is making
a lot of jam and selling it under the
homestead exemption license or anything
like this this is for private basically
private individuals or it's being made
in a private home or on a on a small
farm and being sold to an informed and
consumer
and sometimes you know to do all the L
you know you know maybe somebody doesn't
have the time or they're just making a
meal and they don't have the time to
print out all the labels but they're
telling their informed and consumer hey
you know I just made a spaghetti with uh
some meatballs and this is the what I
put in the meatballs and this is the
sauce I used and I used this type of
meat instead of writing it all out on a
label and you have to label it by weight
technically is how you're supposed to do
that uh this takes this onerous off of
that person and I under you
know there's still local control if
you're running a basically a business
there's still local control and State
Control under the homestead food act
this is a separate entity and there are
a lot of people doing some things like
this but everyone is breaking the law
and aren't we trying to St
people from being not in compliance with
the
that so representative kto I have a
question as to
um the part where it says a producer may
not donate milk to a traditional
Community social event does that mean
that say in Washington New Hampshire
um eart Farms couldn't donate milk to a
uh their local you know event that's
going on in town and why thank you madam
chair and I excluded Dairy because I
didn't want to because dair's one of
those subjects that we always get into
uh especially when dealing with raw milk
and things like that um and uh
because but I can take that out there
was no particular reason I was just
trying to be mindful of everything dairy
uh because I do know of you know Dairy
Producers that do donate their product
for local events that go on and um I
would hate to see them not be able to do
that um Madam chair it was not my intent
to say that they could not donate them
but they could not donate him under the
exemption of not having the milk label
gotcha okay
gotcha okay um they would have to be
under this Homestead or the dairy
regulations for raw milk would we be
able to then amend this line to say a
producer may not donate milk to a
traditional Community social event
unless the milk is labeled and packaged
properly I would most certainly be happy
to do that okay great thank you
representative
Duty yeah I think I need a little
education on this because I thought the
original bill was um focused on people
who sold their meals and I and I know
that this is part of it but now we're
talking about you know um providing food
to a neighbor free of charge and I'm not
sure that that was what was what the
original bill was issued at was was
focused on so you know I guess I don't
have a problem um with not having any
inspections and having an informed
consumer because I noticed when we had
the public hearing we had
219 towns have no food inspection okay
some restaurants never get or they get
inspected so infrequently you know and
if you want to be a consumed Informer
and go to a restaurant go to the
bathroom first and see how they manage
that and if it's not up to your
standards then you may not want to eat
there I mean so you know we have all of
these ways of doing that but you know
I'm I'm just concerned that this might
confuse the law or or might the the way
it's written might add more confusion
than clarification and I don't know I
I'm just asking that question okay
representative
Howard thank you madam chair is this is
this um by the assumption that the the
consumer is informed in the end um does
liability representative kto you may
reply thank you um I think um I don't
know if that would release the person
making it from any
um I don't know if they would actually
be able to get insurance if they weren't
being if they wanted to be insured they
would have to follow different laws
because you know if they were concerned
about that um I think that's extremely
you know they're taking on a personal
responsibility for this so um as we all
know we can be informed and consumers of
anything but it doesn't release the
person the companies of negligence or
liability either right so um I don't
believe that would be the case and
especially in the terms with insurance
they would have to then go under the
Homestead Act I would
believe representative
kraton yeah I me just read back what I
think you just said in other words if I
make my spaghetti M and I tell the
people I just made this spaghetti but my
meat was rancid and I knew the meat was
rancid then I'm still responsible for
that because I I was negligent even
though I said it was the meat that I got
out of the refrigerator but it still ran
and so therefore you're liable for
misrepresentation I would think yeah I'm
sorry go
ahead representative Murray um thank you
madam chair I I guess that's part partly
my question so if if I heard you
correctly in your statement what you
were saying was that um insurance
um if an entity was was selling
uninspected food but sought insurance
how would those two jive with one
another like I I guess that's what I'm
additional um so I haven't spoken with
the insurance company
specifically
however it would be my assumption and we
all know what we assumptions do they
always make fools of us
however uh I know that it is some
insurance has a list of things that they
do not cover in our farm policies and I
don't believe that if we weren't
following a specific thing and this was
a private thing this would not fall
under like for us a farm policy uh so
this would probably have to go under a
separate like homeowners policy or
something to that effect and I don't
know uh because I don't have a regular
homeowners policy so I'm not sure about
insurance
but I wasn't trying to get into the
insurance business or try and figure
that out but
yes represent
Penza so about 10 years ago I had a good
friend that lived across the street that
uh went to school she made cakes and her
her in and she did them she had a full
kitchen in her basement and she was
insured underneath her homeowners policy
she was talking to my husband about it
one night so um if that helps but I
think that this whole bill in a sense is
just giving people a a guideline that is
is necessary so um and to be honest if
if someone wants to sue you for anything
they can sue you so unfortunately we
just live in that culture so um you know
I've been sick many times from a
restaurant and there's never been
anything that I've gotten from that so
you know I trust homemade food probably
better than some of the restaurant
stuffs so I think that this I think this
was a good job thanks
Barbara representative Bixby yeah I
think that um the my guess is that there
are probably
Insurance getting getting this under
getting this allowed under your home
owner's insurance may be problematic or
under your liability umbrella whatever
uh that is that is something that the
person that is doing it has to take on
as a risk
I think that uh there should be a line
in here that says that uh the um that
this this section doesn't of law would
not absolve the homeowner the the
provide producer of any
liability um so um
basically I it uh you know if if the
rancid meat thing were to happen then
you know that would that would be you
know the the home owner the producer
would be liable in that situation and I
I think that there there should not that
that it should explicitly say you know
there's
no this doesn't excuse people from doing
thing but you know that being said I I
actually like the idea of the Bill thank
sorry okay uh any other questions or
comments regarding this no um yeah I
think you did a great job with this um
and I look forward to uh seeing the
amended version that we can then take
action on next
week all
right moving
along
[Music]
326 uh prohibiting the use of second
generation anti-coagulant
rodenticides representative Bixby I
believe um okay you may have something
about that yes I I have a a brief piece
of information I uh discussed this in uh
a bit further with uh director Russo and
uh it sounds like the uh Federal
Regulations are likely to be coming down
in uh December or
January uh we had a the the draft of
those regulations was in the report that
we saw last month um
and uh I think that those what the feds
are proposing is more thorough than what
would happen if we just asked the
department to uh to make these make them
restricted okay uh and anything that
happens with with legislation for us
won't be enacted any sooner than July
uh so um so if there if the feds still
aren't doing doing anything by say late
late spring then we can uh go to we can
ask the the pesticide control board to
consider uh doing something at the state
level and do it through their existing
authorization rather than making a law
and telling them to do it so I think
that we don't need
26 uh so um and i' I'd like to uh thank
the board and for putting together a
study
committee to uh to study this and to and
um sort of thank them for their uh the
thorough report that they put
out okay thank you for that and um I am
in agreement with that uh assessment of
the situation so I uh
thank you for for following up on all of
that and your diligence and your work on
that issue and also to
um Mr rouso for uh his work and his
committee's work on this thank you all
right any any other questions or
comments regarding this HB
326 all
right um so then it is I guess in in our
opinion that next week we would' be itl
this bill yeah
okay all right uh moving on to HB 369
establishing a task force to provide
energy relief on
farms representative Bixby yes so um uh
I had some discussions with uh Ken laali
and Kelly mccadam at uh UNH uh extension
about um what would make sense to do
with this um and they thought that so
currently
uh John Porter who is a longtime uh
member and now an ameritus member of
Cooperative Extension uh has been
working with Farms um maybe once every
week or two uh to make suggestions in
terms of uh Farm Technology and energy
and some including some energy um
systems work but uh that's that hardly
covers the the need within the farming
Community for advising on uh Energy
Systems and um and and other Tech Farm
Technology like Barn ventilation and uh
you know um manure management that sort
of thing so
um so uh in discussion with the
extension folks um we decided that it
what would really make sense is have a
uh program that would uh
that would deal with both Farm Energy
Systems and infrastructure design advice
and
uh and uh I based the the structure of
the bill on the way that the division of
forest and lands does uh works with
Cooperative Extension to have County
Foresters so uh at at this point in the
division of forest and land statutes it
says that the um they have a declared
purpose of uh the forest management
being a benefit to the state I basically
copied their Declaration of purpose and
trans transformed that to farm uh energy
and uh and uh
technology uh
and uh under the forest and Lance
program uh the department of force and
lands has a memorandum of understanding
with Cooper of extension to uh to to
support uh County Foresters in every in
every County to provide the education to
land to uh wood lot owners and and other
um and other um in interested parties in
in forests so uh this would provide this
would be in the Department of
Agriculture it would create the program
would reside in the Department of
Agriculture and they would have a me
memorandum of understanding with uh
extension to have one field specialist
who would work with Farmers to uh
essentially assess the um the on Farm
infrastructure and energy needs and come
up with essentially a holistic uh view
of uh how that could be improved and
then provide the uh farmer
with uh uh the uh resources uh the
information resources to uh find out
what Grant so provide you know
information about what grants are
existent uh what um what would be the
mechanis the available resources for
getting those grants written the field
specialist would not be a grant writer
but uh they you they would have they
would have ACC they would know who is
available for grant writing uh and uh
possib and also know which energy
Alternative Energy Supply ERS might um
be able to help out with the process of
doing re grants for exam for example
uh and so this would provide
a um basically advisory uh resource for
Farmers it is specifically for farmers
who are doing it as
a as a for-profit venture uh so uh I and
I've um the way that I dealt with that
was I defined Farmer for the purpose of
this section as being a farmer who's who
files a schedule F uh with their income
taxes uh so I'm ha I'm happy to take
questions and then I'd like to invite
Seth Wilner up to uh explain how the how
field Specialists work and how this how
this would be a Ben how this would um be
something that um M's first the uh Co-op
extension could provide so um
thank you for that representative Bixby
and I I see we have a number of
questions so representative Murray you
are first um thank you madam chair yes
so one question I did have was that I
see that we're we're depositing this
monies into a general fund but then
we're also standing up a
$100,000 uh appropriation for um uh it
seems like salaries roll ups and
benefits um and one of the things that
I'm curious about is whether or not we
should be maybe establishing a non-aps
dedicated fund for this entity if we are
expecting that um this is something that
will be available year after
year um I when I talked with the
commissioner he felt that it was not
necessary to have a separate uh
dedicated fund for the uh for this and I
think I think I also discussed this with
suami and uh she also um said the
indication was that it was not that it
was uh a reasonable mechanism to have uh
a
um no actually I talked with the LBA
about this so that's that's who I talked
to I talked to suami and she said to
talk to the LBA and I talked to the LBA
and they said that it would it was the
reasonable way to do it was to have uh
any uh if there so I one thing I didn't
mention was that when I talked with the
person at uh USDA who's in charge of the
reap grants she said it was likely that
we could get something like a 50% match
on the cost of this program so that's
that's why the question of donations
comes up so uh we may be able to get
half of the cost of this covered by the
feds um but there's not a guarantee of
that so uh so if there is um so if there
is grant money that will help support it
then that would be deposited in the
general fund and then be appropriated to
the department to pay for the costs
thank you representative ktoa thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
big for taking my question
um where it talks about reports farm
income and
expenses Some Farms have a startup
period it could be 3 to five years
before they see any income um I think
that if you just had a schedule F on
there and not Define because you're
you're limiting that to people that have
farm income
um it's on page one it's on the first
page line and I think you're saying if
I'm hearing you correctly represent
Murray yeah so what you're saying is
that they could be operating at a loss
for several years and so I'll give you
an example if someone wants to start a
Vineyard yeah Vineyards don't don't uh
produce grapes for three to four years
okay so
um basically just files a schedule and
yes
Penza Barbara beat me to that one so the
criteria is um is 1040 schedule F and
how will the communication go out to um
um to all of these folks because of
course you know to announce this that
this is in place is it could be a
tremendous resource for several people
so that's my first question is how will
we communicate to them about this
program and then um the
appropriation for the salary the
$100,000 I just know that if this is
popular and it's one person and you
could have one or two farmers that are
really you know utilizing this and then
that the resources of that one person
will they have um will that's that
salaried person have resources within
the department to help them with this
process
too okay so the um represent Bixby yes
so um the the the $100,000 provides um
the salary benefits and also resources
for so um um travel resources and um
Computer Resources for the that that
typically goes along with an extension
position and I got that that number of
100,000 from uh the director from um
kenl Valley the director of extension so
I assume that he knows what it costs to
do a field specialist in terms of how do
we get the
um uh how how does this get uh um
advertised and how do people know about
it how does extension balance the way
that balance balance it so that farmers
can the maximum number of farmers can
take advantage of it I think I'd like to
turn that over to um Seth wner from
extension so maybe we can bring him up
and he can explain a little bit about
how field Specialists work in
extension thank you good morning and
welcome Mr Wilner good morning and thank
you madam chair my name is Seth Wilner
I've been working with Cooperative
Extension for about 23 years now and I'm
in the farm business management sector
one of the ways that extension um would
be able to easily rise to this and get
word out we have County Educators in
every County all 10 counties then we're
backed Often by um Campus based
Specialists so we have relationships
with all the farms in each of the
counties we also have areas of expertise
so I work around the state in business
management often succession planning and
whole Farm planning the county- based
educator then would either identify a
farm and say Seth could you go work with
this Farm um and we would do the same
with this example here with the um
technology and um energy person or
sometimes if Farmers themselves meet
these people at Twilight meetings or
read news articles or whatever and they
call themselves so there's there's two
mechanisms in through the county agent
or the Farms go directly to to the
person with the specialty area
themselves then in terms of time
consumption so often times we will
work around the state and we'll begin
projects with the Farms give them some
homework come back to the Farms when
they've completed that um and and then
help them get to the next step or
connect them with the resource such as
USDA um nrcs um and or rural development
things of that effect and we don't write
the grants for the Farms themselves but
we certainly Usher them through the
process so there was a farm that
hopefully made the the first round
second round final round and we're
waiting to see if they're going to get
about
$400,000 from the Northeast business
Dairy um Center uh Innovation Center to
effectively do similar to this upgrade
their equipment where they believe by
our calculations 30% increase in
production
of bottled milk so about
$600,000 in gross revenue by low and
lowering their utility bill by about 700
a year so 700 a year is not much but
don't forget that's the increased
production they're going to save a full
day of production and so it's really
from the equipment um that we're going
to we suggested be modernized and their
production methods and that's not even
touching the Renewables you add
Renewables on that you really get
something so there's a lot of area for
um profitability and Improvement and
efficiencies here and that's just with
utilities you look at um technologies
that can save um Fuel and oil and so
there's substantial ability for
savings
okay representative Penza just a quick
followup so the resources so let's say
I'm a farmer and I'm looking and there
is you've provided provided the
information for a grant that's available
of course I have a lot of things that I
need to fill out um but you have someone
that's going to be working with that
farmer the entire time and walking them
through the grant
process yes so as an
example I got the farm together that was
looking at this Innovation um expansion
Grant I said okay here's the strategy
and then who's going to do what roles
and responsibilities same actually what
we do with this succession plan which is
just so much work um so we have they
built an internal team we lead them
through that no question we're calling
and saying hey you're going to follow
through with that homework right that
was due two days ago oh yeah yeah I'm on
that and so sometimes you show up at the
farm you give them a nudge then you get
then you we've all reviewed grants and
extensions so then we're reviewing it or
colleagues are we're like I think I'm
not not really a strong argument here or
you need more data there
then we get feedback um from the
granting agency because there's multiple
rounds and we help them make strategy so
how will you respond to that feedback so
thanks to that effect representative
Katon thank you madam chair I I'm going
back to the $100,000 on page two lines
two and three and
four uh and I'm I'm just confused so
this is what it says is that $100,000
will be allocated to the
department and then it goes on to say
that the appropriation shall be used for
salary benefits expenses okay
so I got that but it's only for one year
so if I go hire Sally to do this job
it's only a oneye job because the
appropriation is only for one year is
that what am I missing something because
you're not going to hire someone for one
year to do this right right so um
the um that's a good question and uh um
the uh I might need to talk with LBA in
terms of uh just to find out how to make
sure that this is a A continuing program
but in terms of um in terms of the
budget cycle this would be um this would
be uh something that in subsequent years
the um the director would the
commissioner would have to put into the
um The Damp the uh Department
budget so
perhaps representative Bixby that in
line one um p on page two that prior to
the
word uh prior to the phrase the sum of
100,000 maybe we should say initially
the sum of 100,000 for the fiscal year
ending is hereby appropriated and then
it would be up to the department uh
subsequently to include that in their
budget representative Murray thank you
madam chair and I guess that was sort of
where I was going with the the Nuance
between it being a general funded Thing
versus a dedicated fund um so to your
point you were saying it would be up to
the Department's discretion then from
here forward to allocate funding after
hearing uh so
um the way that it is phrased here yes
but I'm going to talk to I will talk to
LBA and find out how it needs to be
amended in order to make sure that it is
something that is an ongoing program
okay super representative kraton and and
for a followup just so I'm I'm clear so
what we're saying is we're going to
spend
$100,000 and what we're hoping what we
believe is that that $100,000 will save
or
enhance New Hampshire Farmers ability to
make money by hundreds of thousands of
dollars so we're expecting these grants
to come in based on this $100,000
investment for Farmers of your example
400,000 or whatever the grant
is I see savings for farmers
potentially realized in several ways we
did a um Benchmark study where we looked
at 17 New Hampshire Farms over four
years and utility costs and these were
direct Market vegetable Fruit and
Vegetable Farms minimum gross revenue
was 150,000 per year and then it went up
to 2 million so that was the
range utilities ranged between 8,000 to
31,000 a year and fuel cost range or
8,000 to 21,000 a year and fewer costs
range from 9,000 to 31,000 per year
depending on and and that was the range
so we believe that we could get savings
help realize there what would that
be 4 five 7,000 a year maybe um and for
the direct Vegetable Farms things like
cool Bots things like setting up walking
coolers and having um different um zones
of uh
Refrigeration then the dairy farm Farms
have a higher um utility and they're
between I 10 and 50,000 a year as based
on the figures that I know but they're
not I those aren't as precise as I want
so we'd get help realize savings on the
farm additionally there's a lot of money
out there at least now and projected for
the next five years um where Farms can
go after grants to augment their
technology what is it that they need and
how will it help them save so for
example this $400,000 Grant they wanted
specific amounts of how many kilowatt
hours you would save and they also
wanted specific amounts of how much
diesel to effectively heating oil but
diesel to fuel you would save and so we
were able to go and help them assess
that the Agro the agriculture
Engineering also allow us to um help
them design buildings that would be more
energy efficient but then there's this
Gap as well that um representative Bixby
pointed out in the bill where if I have
to go to you the salesperson for advice
you may not be giving me advice that is
in my best interest you may be giving me
advice that's in the bottom line for you
your best interest we can look at that
and say hm not sure um you might want to
question that a specific example and
then I'll yield the floor back we really
have um some struggles at times with the
lending industry for Farmers when we go
and advise them we say so capital is
like gasoline could burd your farm down
or can really help Propel it do you
really want to take this fixed debt on
and we don't see your return on that
debt we could run our own numbers and
say we don't see your debt repayment
capacity there it's a high risk
everything would need to go right and
they can make a more informed decision
than the lender saying oh no you can do
this this would be great for you so for
followup followup go ahead okay so that
that sounds great but are you doing that
today and if you are doing it today then
why are we spending another
$100,000 to do what you're already doing
because of the limited capacity that we
have in our organization today so John
Porter works one day every other week
and then Sarah Allen is our Dr Sarah
Allen is our Dairy specialist and she
works on all kinds of extra things I
brought her in for this one Farm to help
me because they were in my county and I
was working with them and the grant
review said give us specifics so she was
able to do that it it wasn't ubiquitous
across the state and sadly we are the
only Farm the this was the only Farm in
the state to actually apply for these
funds millions of dollars in Grant funds
being moved through Vermont via the USDA
and it was the only Farm in the state to
apply and we would like to see that be
upgraded thank you thank you
representative Howard thank you madam
chair so so this position would be sort
of a Clearing House of for of resources
and leaz on to those resources so so
that they could be more broadly
used I think that's an apt description
we connect with our colleagues
nationally and regionally to have a
clearing house we also can create
resources
ourselves um through research through
you know aggregating the information
like we did in the Benchmark study we
also would work one-on-one with Farms so
that they have you know the technical
assistance they need um and so all that
information followup go ahead thank you
um so so would this create like a
necessary redundancy or is it a is it a
does it provide new services and and
skills it would do both it would enhance
the ability for us to um serve more
farms and it would also create expertise
in areas we don't have so as as we have
contracted in Cooperative Extension our
ability to gain more subject matter
knowledge has been limited and so
there's so much technology happening so
quickly out there that if it was
someone's job in that sector that they
could really enhance and and take
advantage of those
opportunities representative viby yeah
one of the things that um an example of
one of the things that this position
would help uh in terms of bringing money
into the state is there is currently in
the USDA I think called the the reap
grants the rural energy something or
other program uh
and uh that is that provides grant
funding for energy uh uh Alternative
Energy uh or like solar and wind Etc uh
for uh rural businesses including farms
and the definite it's a small rural
small businesses their definition of a
small business is $50 million or less uh
and if you're talking about a a a family
farm in New Hampshire competing against
a business that is you know even $25
million that New Hampshire Farm doesn't
have the um the the Personnel Resources
to figure out everything that needs to
be figured out for is this the is this
the right grant what and and you know I
looked at the list of things you need to
provide for the reap grants it's an
awful lot of paperwork and uh so so
sorting through that paperwork is
something that is you know you might
look at that paperwork and say oh God I
can't do that I have all these other
things I need to do so if there's
someone if there's a Cooperative
Extension specialist who can help uh the
farmer figure out what they need to do
you know what what they need to do in
order to get that paperwork that could
result in a grant for um you know 100
you know 100,000 to million dollars of
potential depending on on the scale
that's NE necessary of potential grant
funding for energy resources for the
farm and uh I looked at the list of who
in New Hampshire is getting those reap
grants a very small portion of it like
under 20% of the uh of New Hampshire uh
businesses that are getting reap grants
are farms it's mostly rural you know
other rural businesses uh and not that I
not that I have anything against other
rural businesses but I think that our
Farmers need to have a shot at these
grants they're there they will
definitely uh provide long-term better
sustainability for the farms uh and I
mean both both ecological and more
importantly I think uh economic
sustainability for the Farms so that is
why we need someone who uh we we really
need a specialist who at extension who
is uh
really has got the the technical knowhow
the energy knowhow to do that farm
advising for that specific Niche and I
think that you know um the broader you
what you discussed earlier in terms of
you know that example of uh the farm
that you helped get these resources for
that was part of your you know you were
wearing your business advisor hat on in
that and
uh that is but the energy part is not
your specialty so someone who has that
energy part will that energy specialty
and that uh that farm engineering
specialty will be able to go into a farm
and see that infrastructure Energy
System and other infrastructure part of
it and be able to really look at it
holistically and make more targeted
recommendations and that's I I think
that would really help bring in that
grant funding that uh will make this you
know pay
multifold thank you representative
Murray thank you madam chair um one of
the things that I'm wondering and this
is maybe um just a learning curve for me
I just wanted to make sure that when
we're talking about schedule F does that
does a schedule F or is a schedule F
something that other like Coastal
communities may also fill out when it
comes to aquaculture or things so this
is
the schedule is specifically for Farms
so if it's muscle farming is that it
could be it could yeah I I I it could be
aquaculture far if aquaculture Farms are
considered Farms so oh sorry so so it
could be uh I I believe that um I or
maybe could you might know more about
do many farms fill out the schedule F
Some Farms also have a Schedule C that
they fill out um for the specific
non-dairy production and this in this
case it looks like it's being used as a
tool only um to distinguish between
commercial farms and not commmercial
farms and so that I would probably add
Schedule C for the the value added the
processors um as well uh
but you also could just put a a mandate
that the Farms have to have whatever
minimum amount of gross income you
wanted depending on if you wanted to
distinguish from size but your choice oh
that's in
there uh representative k sorry thank
you recognize you there you go um I just
looked up the schedule F and uh just to
give you an idea of uh animal production
is beef cattle ranching and farming
cattle feed Lots dairy cattle and milk
production hog and pig farming poultry
and egg production sheep and goat
farming aquaculture and other animal
production and that was just under
Productions there other uh items listed
such as Crop Production forestry and
logging are also part of schedule
F okay representative
Penza so representative Bixby would you
be okay with adding and if it needed to
have some criteria on there the schedule
C um I think okay so uh I just need a
little clarification is Schedule C only
value added production and that's
separated from so would that be uh so
let's say
um the North Country Smokehouse would
they uh they would have a schedule C but
not a schedule F is that right I don't
claim to be a tax F expert but I do
believe that's correct all non um all
the um retail Farm stands Schedule C
labor and and whatnot and so the milk
processing plants Schedule C so we have
um home B bottlers there so that would
be I don't know Rob Johnson do you have
Johnson we've had this issue before and
my understanding is that only sole
proprietor proprietorships are required
to file a Schedule F other a partner
ship Corporation does not need to we
again this this type of language has
been proposed in the past and we have
always opposed it because you are
cutting out a segment for
eligibility so we would add Schedule C
to
this I don't know enough to if that does
it I just know that not all Farms file a
Schedule F okay yeah good to know I stay
there for a sec because I wanted to kind
of I wanted to kind of get your your uh
your feedback about this um amendment to
this
bill I really I've just had the
discussion and the schedule left was one
the issue that jumped out to me okay
research that representative Bixby so
the the point of having the schedule
left there is that we wanted so you know
I have I have a homestead Garden
operation that that we basically just
feed ourselves with I don't think I
should be eligible for this spe for
working with this special
uh I you know I think that um like um
but I I I want it to be Farms that are
actually in the business of farming as
opposed to uh the broader definition
that we have in um in uh RSA 21 I I
understand why you want it there and I I
think we agree with that philosophy but
I'm just telling you that not all Farms
that are eligible that our Farms would
be uh able to apply the language is
there a way that we could make that
distinction without excluding those for
there may be we'd have to do some
research I I just know there's been
legislation in the past that has
proposed a schedule F piece in my tenure
two three four five times I've I've come
across this where I've had to explain
that it it it it just doesn't you're
you're limiting a segment of the ad
Community legitimate F represent
K thank you madam chair and I think
there's some confusion so a schedule F
is when you file a form 1040 if you are
a partnership or a corporation or a C
Corp sorp whatever you're either filing
a form 1065 or
1120 they're not the
forms representative
Murray thank you madam chair I was
wondering if this
would we're clearly not going to get to
a a
a solid answer but I think we need to
seek out some other re revisit some
other areas so is that possible that we
can uh representative Bixby are you open
to to circling back with LBA and some
other yeah um yeah I'd be open to um to
seeing if we can find a another way to
narrow it um that doesn't use the
schedule F
uh um Mr
Wimer what we did with the farm Mental
Health
$200,000 was allocated in the binal
budget and so as we narrow down that
program you have to be a farm owner and
you have to have we took the phraseology
from the tax code that said you had to
have some liability you have to um we
could get the exact language but it said
effectively you had to be a business
with with liability in there so we have
that language that we used for the
farmer mental health bill that and we
also made it that you had to be a farm
owner owner because we had limited um
funds we couldn't serve everybody in the
F mental health so that language is
easily had I don't know it off the top
of my head sadly but I know where to
find it in a heartbeat well if you could
send that to me then I can put it into
an amendment thank you absolutely
representa
Duty yeah I'm looking at uh the last
five years of the uh reap program and
I'm just wondering if maybe we're being
too granular on this uh because I'm not
sure that that representative Bixby
would you know want to fill out all of
the paperwork for a $3,000 or a $4,000
Grant you know I mean I'm looking these
grants are are pretty small so I mean I
think if we have some
generic um language in the bill that
doesn't you know some people may fall
through the cracks and they you know
they may want to spend you know a half a
year of their life you know to get one
of these grants but you know I'm not
sure that's it's really that big of an
issue pres fixby okay so and this is not
solely about reap grants and the reap
grants have been uh the the funding that
came through the inflation reduction act
for repr Grants has bumped up the amount
significantly so um so the so the
average might might not be that you know
the the I i' I'd have to look up the
amounts again but um but I I know that
it's um
that there is um there is more available
uh under that program there is ALS there
are also a number of other grants out
there that I couldn't name off the top
of my head that could be relevant in
this situation it's not just about the
reef grants it's about uh other grants
that would be available for Farm energy
farm in infrastructure and that's
something that we would want a field
specialist to be knowledgeable about uh
and certainly more knowledgeable than I
uh representative Bixby I um was
thinking about this um line 15 and 16 on
page
one and I wonder if we can say something
to the effect that
um definition of for the purpose of this
subdivision Farm means a farming
operation
um that is farming for profit and
reports to the IRS would that kind of
cover all bases or it may but I think
that um Mr Wilmer had uh made reference
to a uh some language that's in the in
the uh Farm mental health bill that
exists that does the job that might do
the the the job that we want so I'd like
to see and he's going to get that
language to me so um when I get that
language I can distribute it to the okay
Penza so just so I understand in regards
with the the funding the $100,000 so it
it's underneath the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture markets and
food but then they're Contracting out to
you guys for that position is that how
it works M yeah correct that would be
how that works follow up yeah sure so I
know that representative big is going to
go back on this but to me you know I
know we're going to add maybe in there
initially 100,000 and um but there's no
you know there's no language in here if
this let's say this is successful you
know no three year no five year there's
nothing so this possibly could be a
oneandone so if that happens and it
doesn't get into a budget for next time
what does that mean we would have to go
back to this drawing board again
represent
com thank you madam chair I believe that
the memorandum of understanding has to
be reviewed and updated every 3 years or
less as may be necessary if you look at
one
yeah represent
Duty yeah I would also uh make people
aware that in our 10 counties uh each of
the counties uh does add funding in
their budget for UNH extension okay and
so in Hillsboro County for example which
I would assume is the least rural County
uh I mean if you divide $100,000 up by
10 counties we're talking $10,000 each
and if we found that this program was a
benefit to our farmers in Hillsboro
County uh I don't think it would be a
big issue in the county to add an
additional 10,000 000 to the money we
all already give to UNH extension
because we're providing a direct
economic benefit to our Farmers um and I
think in all of the counties we really
appreciate the farmers and want to
assist them in anyway so that could be
although we certainly would want the
state to you know uh support this
program I really do think that each of
the counties uh would recognize the
benefit representative
thank you madam chair I just want to uh
reinforce representative Duty's point
you know I mean ideally yes this goes
into kind of the next budget as a
request from the Department uh but even
if I hate to put it in these terms the
worst case scenario it's just the
one-year funding to to begin with I
think that when we see the results right
then I think that that is going to be
the best argument for uh more
contributions from counties uh and more
contribution uh from the state so I
think that the results over the course
of that one year will be a really good
argument for more investment
representative BBY okay so um I
appreciate the the support on that but I
think that in ter I sit on the advisory
Council for uh the extension in in
straford County uh and in terms of the
way that the budgeting works for uh the
County extension and for um the
extension that's based at at UNH uh that
the the idea of having the counties chip
in individually for this particular
position just really wouldn't work with
the way that it's being set up uh the so
the uh Cooperative Extension has done a
great deal of work in terms of figuring
out how to balance their resources in
the counties and what gets paid for by
the counties and what what's home what
has a home at un and what gets paid for
through the uh the state the chunk of
the state budget that goes to UNH and
then gets you know some of that get
split off for the extension and also
what the what extension does through
memorandum uh memoranda of of
understanding which is the way they pay
for pay for Foresters uh
so uh I I think that this is that um the
we essentially this need I need to I do
need to write to make an amend amend
this in order to make sure that it's
clear that this is a um a multi-year
program uh and that the it needs to be
appropriated each um the the sufficient
appropriation needs to be made uh from
um to the department to cover it every
year but uh I don't think that asking
the count ities to to chip in is is
going to is a is a workable solution for
it um but um and did I get that right do
don't they chip in for uh for the
don't the the county budget if I'm
correct gives
25% of all the extension Educators
salaries yeah and on the county basis
not for the program managers not for any
admin ative support and so it does not
cover any of the Statewide um people so
our Campus based Specialists have to
bring in 25% of their own salary with
grants and they um and this is a hybrid
though this is not a state specialist
nor is this a county based specialist it
is a Statewide field specialist okay so
it probably wouldn't be funded by county
and they wouldn't have the the grant
obligation to it um I also would ask
also allow you not allow you um bring to
your awareness sorry Chris Callahan from
the University of Vermont um is a
similar out to the same position so you
could look at all the engineering you
could look at all the energy
efficiencies you could look at all the
other um ways that he has brought
technology to farms in Vermont that has
helpful thank you any other questions or
comments regarding this um Amendment one
more um one more represent Dy this is
just a comment in general just because
it isn't doesn't mean it can't
be I mean I think a little vision going
forward if we think it's an important
program just because we don't have a
mechanism to fund it now doesn't mean we
can't create a mechanism to fund it now
if we feel that it is a viable program
program that assists our economy and
assists our and assists our Farmers just
want to make that comment thank you
representative Murray uh thanks Madam
chair and I I I do say that uh I hear
representative dsy and I think that
might be a larger conversation for an
association of counties or some other
conversation because it's not just one
County that would have to have that
conversation thank
you anyone
else all right so um I guess um
representative Bixby you've got some
homework and
uh hopefully you can get your assignment
done before next
Tuesday thank you very much thank
you
Road all right moving right along thank
you Mr Winer and uh and also uh Mr
Johnson for your input on
this the last bill that we're going to
discuss this afternoon is I mean this
morning is 8 HB 602 relative to landfill
sighting and I believe that
representative H Haskins and
representative Penza would like to say a
few
words representative H Haskins I defer
to my colleague to start us off all
right representative Penza you have the
floor oh the ball's in my court oh there
you go all right so um I had all this
other all this other stuff that I'm
going to say probably within questions
and stuff but um this bill basically is
you know original 602 puts the cart
before the horse in a sense because we
have rules that are uh at this point um
underway so this actually this bill puts
the horse first and we are which is
mind-boggling to me as more I learn
we're you know one of the only States
right now that doesn't have a
preliminary application this is this is
good for all involved it's good for of
course the state but it's it's just as
good for the industry um to be able to
have criteria in place that which is
also you know automatically um a
non-starter for putting a landfill in so
um you know just in some preliminary
looks for example you know Massachusetts
which is actually not permitting any new
landfills at all they have a three-phase
process um Vermont who's not permitting
new landfills you know they have a very
extensive one phase but there won't be
another landfill probably in Vermont
Maine has a two-step process
Pennsylvania has a a two-phase process
Oregon South Carolina Maryland and I can
go on so um this basically you know it
reviews the site you know suitability um
report and it determines like whether a
parcel meets criteria for uses of
landfill that is really um the gist of
this bill it really is the exact same
bill as before it's just with you know
like kind of every instance where we had
you know Dees um saying that it was
shall uh it's now actually giving Dees
um their own ideas to come up with it of
whether you know to designate you know a
New Hampshire site uh a poor location
for new landfills um you know I have a a
whole slle of reasonings in here that
just make sense um but for example like
environmental impact assessment you know
right now you have um you can have a the
industry will come in and they will
spend tens of thousands of dollars uh
you know working the land
and they would lose all of that money
how how we have it set up and this
preliminary application process you know
it also includes you know public input
especially for a location and stuff like
that local residents stakeholders um to
get all of that information in place but
if if the ground is it just doesn't make
sense for it to be there and Das already
knows those criteria you're going to
save so much resources not just for the
industry side of things they'll save
money but also for Dees in general and
we all know that um Dees is very much
strapped for time just like we all are
and their resources are slim um they've
just lost their um their second in
command and so yeah so this this piece
could really help them the only thing
that's missing in this amendment that
OLS they might have just missed it is a
it would be at the
end and it would
say basically recognizing that there's
additional work Dees um must put put
into this rul making um the July 2024
deadline to revise EnV sw800 is extended
for one year until July 2025 this is not
saying that they they can't have it done
in time but if they're going to have um
this preliminary application piece which
just makes sense and mirrors so many
other states then they can have you know
an an extra you know an extra year to be
able to put it in representative Bixby
yeah actually to that point I just
noticed um on page two line one uh not
withstanding RSA 541a administrative
rule uh envs w800 shall remain in effect
until July 21 July 1 2025 or until re
reopt rules are effective that's
basically the way that uh OS translated
that what you were looking
for so that so basically uh that that's
that's what delays the the due date of
the rules okay perfect thank you so you
don't need to amend it okay it's good as
this representative
kraton okay so I agree with everything
you're saying I just I'm confused which
probably the standard State of Affairs
uh so we just went through a whole thing
about
uh the the rules and defining and we
said no you don't need $200,000 you
don't need another person you don't need
to do a contract just go ahead and write
the rules and so then we established a
subcommittee that said oh by the way go
ahead and establish the rules and we're
going to check your homework which is
fine that's our job and and and that's
good but now what we're saying is go
ahead and write the rules we're going to
check our homework and oh by the way
next June when this passes we're going
to change everything we told you to do
in the first place and so that's that's
the way I'm reading this so let me just
offer and if I'm wrong tell me I'm wrong
it's not the first time but it would
seem to me that this would be something
we would tell them to write this into
the rules hey you guys are doing the
rules you're reviewing it put this into
the rules as you're writing them and
they don't need a separate law to change
the table after they've already written
the rules
so I I guess that's my question that I'm
I'm a little
baffled represent
Penza oh representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair actually what we're
trying to say is that we believe
strongly that in order to get the
integrity and transparency in the
process we need this phase one
permitting because that will St save
time and money by Dees if they can show
that certain sites are clearly
landfill representative
kraton fair enough I and I agree with
that my point is though that then that
will have to be put into rules no and so
why don't we just tell them to put that
into the rules as they're writing them
now to say hey put this in there and and
and then we can monitor that through the
subcommittee process and then you don't
go through another year worth of debate
and you don't go through a whole you
know I mean they're not going to get
this until June or July the earliest
over representative
ger uh thank you uh I want to say that
um I along with a number of other
legislators uh on both sides of the
aisle including representative Penza we
met with Dees in August to talk about uh
some of the things that have happened
and our as aspirations for you know how
things were going to go forward and one
of the things that we talked about was
was the relationship with Dees and the
legislature and the need to have on the
one hand appropriately explicit guidance
provided by the legislature and
discretion for Dees to be able to figure
out how to make it work right and and I
think that this amendment does that very
very well it does not prescribe any
content at all right so we're not
telling them what rules they have to
write or how they have to write them
unlike the original 602 so there's lots
of latitude and discretion for Dees but
it also provides them with guidance in
terms of the process uh and and so I
would say that we are telling Dees as
they're working on rules and giving them
a little bit more time if they need to
incorporate this into rules that this is
the structure of the process right that
is going to say Dees time it's going to
take save time for applicants it is
going to result in a better process but
we're doing that
without telling
Dees how to do their jobs in terms of
what the content of the rule writing is
going to be so based on those
conversations and as I said really
good conversations and work done on a
very bipartisan basis and obviously this
amendment is offered by our colleagues
on both sides of the aisle I think this
strikes that really nice balance between
guidance
and discretion for
Dees represent Bixby yeah so I think
that uh one thing to remember is that
the rules that Dees is currently working
on are for essentially they're updating
the existing rules uh in terms of how
the perating process works and what this
amendment what this bill will do uh this
amended bill will do is create a
different a second layer of Permitting
so what this so this is not actually
going to interrupt any of the stuff that
Dees is already doing for their uh July
2024 deadline what it's going to do is
add another piece of the process that
they don't have yet and
uh consistent with what rep germano was
saying uh what this Amendment does is it
provides direction from us without
being um
micromanaging
and uh we could not we could not in fact
go to Dees informally and say could you
put this in because they don't have the
power to do that what gives them a power
to do that is when we pass a bill like
this so uh so in order for for Dees to
create a pre permitting process they
need to have the legislative authority
to do
that or authorization to do
that um be before we get to anybody
else's
questions the only concern I have about
this is that even though this touches
the same
RSA 149 DM
col9 we are setting up a new preliminary
permit application process and my
concern is the germanness of this
language
that it would it would appear that we
would need um some sort of new public
hearing to have various uh people weigh
in on setting up a a preliminary permit
application which is a process we don't
currently have
um can you reply to that or comment on
Penza so I've spoke
with uh the I spoke with the clerk
specifically about this and at first
look which is almost exact to um what I
submitted he said that it was Germain
and I was okay with this so and he was
okay with it I can send this back to him
again the the only thing that's
different in this is basically saying
cuz all the rules we're not we're not
this wouldn't be something that they're
going to put into rules all the rules
that they're currently in the process of
doing are getting done this is basically
saying okay well when an application
comes in all those rules that you've
just spent all that time on if you know
that they're going to put it you know
right next right in sandy soil right
next to a body of surface water problem
whatever it may be next to a private
well whatever I mean so that it would
automatically be something that's
discarded based upon the rules that are
written we don't have that and which is
crazy that we don't because it's it's
it's almost a given in every other state
so that one piece um that process piece
is is really instead of us telling them
because we're not telling them what
they're going to do it's basically what
they're telling us and I don't know I
don't know if we would need another
um um public hearing for this I think it
still Falls all under the same but um I
can check if you'd like me to
yes represent Howard thank you madam
chair um it seems to me that that we are
doing them the favor of um providing an
an efficiency to the process because um
if you as you just said um if you apply
the rules early in the process you can
you're you're eliminating spending more
money either as as the as a proponent or
as the agency um pursuing something that
that under the rules would not
proceed representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair it's also true that the
Senate hasn't seen 602 yet so of course
that is time for a public hearing at
that juncture but I think that the
original bill
had all those prescriptions and so what
we've done is shortened that up and
said that could be said to be a a first
stage permit process but we've said okay
let's call it a stage one permit process
instead of all the fine lines about that
was in the bill originally we've
shortened that up but it was in effect a
permit process by having all those
condition
itions so that much hasn't really
changed we're just shortening it calling
it what it is and then giving Dees the
discretion that they need to do the ru
making represent Bixby yeah so um first
of all I think this bill makes an awful
lot of sense um and based on uh What uh
representative Penza reported in terms
of her her conversation with Paul with
uh clerk Smith
I think that um that it sounds very much
like uh he has deemed this to be Germain
uh it might be worth having just a a
second followup with the now that it's
been fully drafted but um but I think
that uh we could probably be fairly
confident that uh however much it
changed in drafting is not going to make
a difference and we can uh if it turns
out that it is in fact not
um would we have time before our
deadline to for retained bills to have a
okay representative German thank you
madam chair I just want to very briefly
reinforce uh the point that was made
well by representative H Haskins right
that in 602 previously there was a whole
set of criteria right that we said that
people had to meet uh in this case um
it it gives again that discretion piece
to Dees it says that they'll adopt one
or more prohibitive locational criteria
right so that instead of that long
prescriptive list it's up to Dees and it
could be a much simpler set of criteria
which will expedite that process for
Dees as well as
applicants representative
Murray thank you madam chair I did have
one other question I guess regarding um
which page one subsection three so
that's lines 22 through
24 um one of the so it seems to me that
that piece of language is really
considering what I think we have been
discussing for some time is what what I
would say are potentially cumulative
impacts um and I was just curious it
mentions directly um greenhouse gas
admissions as a Baseline and I just
wanted to make sure that we have that
information or that data somewhere to be
able to say that we are making that
um we're asking for that
information can yep representative
Penza so this is basically it's it's
it's giving a list of what Dees might
consider so this
isn't they might not consider that we
just put a whole series of these things
in here that while they're in the
process of making their their rules most
likely they are considering all of these
things so this isn't um this isn't us
telling them anything we're you know of
course you know needless greenhouse gas
emissions Highway congestion traffic
congestion traffic accidents or other
negative impacts we're just putting we
just basically put a little bit of a
laundry list of the things that they're
already considering so for example if
the rules come back and they have that
you know for example that line line
three is mentioned in there and someone
an application well it's and it's going
to have a huge issue let's say if it's
right up north you know um oneway
Highway type of thing that you know with
massive trucks and heavy equipment and
all would create a huge burden for an
area then of course if that's what Dees
has already put in there in their rul
making then that would restrict an
application automatically so this isn't
asking them to to do anything we just
put a whole series of different criteria
that's
it
representative Duty uh yes thank you
madam chair um we recently in nashwa had
a public hearing uh with
Dees uh regarding an ashalt plant um we
had all of the key players from Dees
there uh and they called this meeting
basically um as a nod to EP EPA that um
is encouraging um
Environmental Services organizations to
have more public input so um this was a
way of them coming to nashwa and
educating uh the residents and
interested individuals on what Dees
requires for permitting and this was the
air resources um department and one of
the uh the uh previous um Deputy
Commissioner was there and was very
clear and we clarified it with him
several times okay that in the
permitting process they can only take
into
consideration um technical
information okay related to the permit
so if you have so in other words for the
ashalt plant um as long as the permit as
long as the plant meets the technical
requirements that the public can have no
other input into the process
regarding the fact that 50 trucks a day
might be going past there you know that
they might be idling at 6:00 a.m. in the
morning and spewing out diesel fuel none
of that can be considered and when we
clarified that there were two tracks um
the technical track only that would be
considered and then what the
neighborhood might be uh um concerned
about he verified that they only take
into consideration technical
and so when we talked about the
cumulative impacts he's um rep uh
commission Deputy Commissioner sandborne
said that currently is not in statute
and therefore we cannot take that into
consideration so I just want to be clear
that we are putting that into statute
now if this gets passed and that's
what's of concern you know to our our
residents people walked out of there and
said then why should we even show up for
a public hearing because I can I can
tell you there there's probably only one
or two people in nashwa who have the
technical expertise to look at a permit
and question it the vast majority of
people you know they don't want to smell
they don't want to hear they don't want
to poison their kids but Dees cannot
take that into consideration right now
so so I mean I think this is this these
lines 22 to 24 are really
critical representative
Howard are we by by including these
things in here are we assuming that
they're in the rules and and um and
we've differentiated before between
statutes and and rules so um I'm just
wondering if if we're putting things in
here that can't that if they don't make
it into the rules they're irrelevant
right
Penza we would assume that these are the
things that are considered as you know
our rules are like slimmed to none right
now so we're we're we're hoping and
through meetings and I was at those
meetings as well um they have said that
they they would like instruction so this
is just in a sense some instruction yes
guidance but it of course you know this
this could be 10 pages long if we were
going to go based upon all of the
different criteria so this was just here
as as you know I want to say kind of
like a placeholder but these are the
things that you would consider right
that in a sense if the these these
criteria weren't met that it would be an
automatic denial for an application and
then you don't have you know a company
that has spent you know tens of
thousands of dollars already doing
sighting um of course the well work all
of that kind of stuff that has to be
done which is very expensive so it just
makes sense to have that these are
certain things that are they're just
kind of the criteria that we're familiar
with just from what the research has
been done representative
kraton thank you madam chair did um when
you talked to Dees what was their
response to this was
there to this bill yeah to this bill I
have I have not spoken with Dees in
regards with this okay we had um you
know there were meetings the summer and
stuff like that but that weren't
specifically for that I mean we knew we
weren't going to put be putting in any
new you know
um HB 56 type bills or HB you know this
this amendment is is really in place to
give you know Dees The Authority that
they want and also the public input the
beauty of this is is that there's before
something gets rubber stamped that that
the community is going to have input
there's going to be public input which
is great on all sides and I and I think
that's what's so important um
so okay but we so we don't I'm sorry so
we don't know what Dees de hadn't seen
this they have not seen it I'm gonna say
they're going to over the wall and we
hope it doesn't go off okay
representative Duty I would just say
that in in talking to D Dees on a number
of things normally they don't take a
position you know they just normally
don't take a position yeah
so represent ger uh thank you and I I
want to point out two things Madam chair
uh number one again just to emphasize
the importance also on uh in terms of of
the applicants right and and clarifying
A process for the applicants in this
case the importance of line 11 uh which
is that or 10 and 11 an application that
does not pass such a preliminary screen
shall be returned to the applicant
without prejudice right so I think
that's also an important piece of this
bill that it is also to the benefit of
the applicant they get that feedback if
if if it's an immediate no with the
opportunity then to to to to to resubmit
uh and and also uh I think that again
based on conversations previously with
Dees I think that this strikes the
balance that they have repeatedly asked
for between guidance and disc
discression representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair I I just want to
also ask I guess ask the question
because in in previous testimony that we
have received from the Department around
this topic um there have been um
instances which the department has said
to an applicant for various reasons and
parts of their applications that things
had to go back so I'm
curious um well I understand that uh the
department may not take a position that
doesn't mean
that um they don't follow the potential
language or they don't those kinds of
things so I would be interested to this
doesn't sound like something entirely
uh new in that sense that there the
preliminary portion yes new but there
have been times in which from my
understanding um applications have
been po or portions of the application
have been re-referred back to the
applicant
okay representative H Haskins thank you
uh Madam chair I want to Second what my
colleague um representative Duty said
she said it better than I um Dees is
looking to us for guidance we are giving
them the guidance and I think all that's
been said about the bill you know we
still have time if we need to to get
further input uh um but we are giving
Dees the job that they're paid to do
that they're there to do and our job is
to tell them what we
want thank you representative
Penza so I just wanted to reiterate um
the point that representative ger made
which is is great without prejudice so
and I also I just I think I want to um
just speak to what you said Megan it
from what I'm from what I know basically
the applications have only come back
because they were incomplete not not in
this state that they basically were okay
well there's a criteria that's met so um
and that's really kind of a a whole
different situation so um not about it
has never has anything to do with
picking the wrong site and and usually
at that point when an application has
been put in there's also been there's
been you know money spent at that Point
as well
representative anyone
else any other questions or comments
regarding this
amendment
um Okay I uh I am just interested to
make sure that um we
uh that this that this amendment is
germine um I I don't want to be setting
up um you know a new
process uh and we I don't really believe
we have enough time to do any kind of
public hearing on it um so with that in
mind um I I do hope that you will take
the the um Amendment as it's been
drafted to um the the house Clerk and
perhaps even to the speaker for um a
ruling on whether it's Germaine or not
so yeah after this I can walk over if um
if clerk um Smith is there I will hand
it to him and I'll get you guys
hopefully an answer today okay great any
other questions or comments regarding
this okay with that uh that sort of uh
finishes up our discussions for the
bills that we had in front of us today
um we are scheduled to meet next Tuesday
at 10:00 to exec these retained
bills and um if there's anything else
that anyone else has for the good of the
committee please let me know uh
represent ger uh I had a question I
thought when I received the schedule for
next week that we were executing in the
afternoon at 1 p.m. I believe that's
because I and I ask and I hope that's
true because I have my our last extended
area permit meeting in the morning so
we're doing the executing in the
afternoon in the morning we're doing the
subcommittee on
rules that's at 10: okay on the 24th I
I'll just I had the calendar right here
oh they no so they have so if you look
on uh on the calar they flipped it yeah
okay so uh that yeah that is that is
correct actually um so for October mber
24th at 10:00 a.m. the subcommittee on
Dees rules update is meeting and then at
1 p.m. we will have our executive
session thank you for clarifying that I
had completely forgot we had that I had
switched it yeah all right so then I
guess we'll see you at 1 o'clock on next
Tuesday instead of 10: a.m. so yeah 10:
a.m. is the subcommittee and then one
o00 is our exec session and we have six
bills to uh that will be dealt with
um I suppose probably around 12:30 we
would have uh any kind of caucus for the
Republicans um anyway anything else for
anybody then I would call to adjourn our
meeting and uh thank you very much for
your time and your really great
questions and um input to uh all of
these bills that we are are dealing with
day